it's hard to explore gaming news browse
steam or even scroll through twitch
mixer or YouTube without seeing the
words Battle Royale
over the past year it's become a term
that's as recognizable as deathmatch or
catch the flag when it comes describing
gameplay or new titles it's ubiquitous
term but it's use immediately calls to
mind two separate games player announced
battlegrounds and fortnight and while
there are many out there that think this
style of game is the freshest phenomenon
it's actually been simmering under the
surface of game development for years
after the incredible success of pub geom
fortnight is burst into the spotlight
its popularity propelled by developers
big and small working to make the most
of the trend from movie inspirations
mods and standalone successes I'll be
giving you a brief history of fat
surrounding games I may miss out the
obscure mod here or an e joke title
there but if you're watching this
between chicken dinners this should give
you a good grasp on how the Battle
Royale phenomenon became to be
[Music]
in fair game no he's not attractive
Aquino grew cotton our older man was Oh
the core concepts behind battery l
namely participants being forced to
fight to the death the zones of danger
and the sole survivor being the victor
originates from the og battle royale a
novel written by koi Shinto kami that
was later developed into 2000s epic
movie Battle Royale
directed by Kinji Fukasaku for anyone
who's not seen the movie what are you
doing with your life go and watch it
here's a quick breakdown the film exists
in a fascist Japan with the government
passing the BR act to control Japan's
unruly youth as you'd imagine the BR act
revolves around a battle taking place
middle school students are taken to an
island fitted with explosive collars and
given basic supplies and three days to
fight to the death until one remains
unclear if any chicken dinner was
involved
the 2012 movie The Hunger Games based on
their own series of books featured many
themes similar to battle from the
dystopian government and fights into the
death to the tense one-on-ones where
you're rooting for the underdog the two
movies have many commonalities
however Hunger Games brought the idea of
a battle royale to a younger audience
made him more accessible and added much
more story and drama across four films
it was through these movies that we saw
the first battle royale / Hunger Games
style titles and mods emerge
minecraft had more mods than my house
had creeper holes shortly after the
release of The Hunger Games a battle
royale mode named Hunger Games was
released for Mojang's title the name was
later changed to survival games to avoid
obvious legal issues personally I
remember watching the mine crack series
with folks like ethos lab pause and
pause and be tableau they were my first
introduction into the mod even before
I'd seen The Hunger Games Movies the
formula between the game in the movie
were very similar 24 players would
started a sense with a map which housed
chests and various equipment you could
choose to fight over that gear at the
start hoping for a diamond sword or some
enchantments or flee into the
surrounding map to find other chests
obviously minecraft it's all of our
building and while that aspect was taken
out of the survival games due to the
relative ease in which people could use
minecraft to create incredible buildings
and scenery
many maps were soon appearing on
survival servers these new maps
introduced a great deal of variety
bringing huge dense forests to explore
cities and skyscrapers to fight over
deserts and tunnel systems to get lost
in puzzles and even platforming sections
to reward you with the best loot also
you could be better equipped to fight
the final battle and become the sole
survivor minecraft was a game I used to
play to relax but this mode despite its
quaint appearance and simple gameplay
core could still create more exciting
moments than defending a house from a
charged creeper it helped popularize an
experience that would be built upon
again and again over the years the mode
was later developed on four consoles in
2016 as the minecraft battle minigame
the play account was restricted to eight
and it featured a showdown mode at the
end but at its heart it was still the
Hunger Games experience all in a much
blockier form
[Music]
[Music]
originally Daisy started as a personal
project by Dean Hall who created a
persistent post-apocalyptic zombie
filled survival sandbox but there's been
a lot of changes since Daisy was born as
an ARMA 2 mod and became its heights
another survival genre the Battle Royale
element came to the game the following
year with another mod - Daisy a mod of a
mod if you will it also served as a
testing grounds for her name you'll
recognize if you've been playing pub G
Brendan Green aka player unknown himself
would make his first steps into the
battle onra within dayz Greenwood build
the dayz battle royale with the Japanese
battle royale film in mind using a
newfound confidence in creating his own
mods after spending some time managing
and experimenting with level design in
dayz Cherno plus in dayz battle royale
the starting locations will be similar
to that of The Hunger Games where
players would be surrounding a pile of
loot and other choice to take a risk and
nab themselves a backpack or head into
the hills and find weapons and supplies
in the surrounding world instead of a
zone of gas or electricity the game
would force you into the ending play
zone by infinitely spawning zombies
around you until you made it to the
final circle during development
Greenwood experiment with players
engaging with a game outside of the
player will experience firmly believing
that a strong background was a hugely
important factor to the success and
excitement of a game towards this he
created this teaser image alongside a
short story to generate excitement
within the dayz community this move
obviously works well and it would be a
strategy Greenwood continued to employ
on follow-up projects however it was
ultimately the memorable stories from
its players experiences within this game
that attracted others to it when Daisy
went standalone Brennen Greenwood turns
ARMA 3 to continue his work and it's at
this stage he began tying his work to
the moniker player unknown being the new
game ARMA 3 generated a lot of attention
and quickly established an active
modding and create a scene for player
unknown this allowed for quick
iterations alterations and testing of
new ideas there are many aspects to the
ARMA 3 battle royale that would be
familiar to anyone playing pub G instead
of The Hunger Games star spawning around
a central area players were dropped in
from a plane and had to parachute into
the play zone supply drops would appear
in red and blue crates that were
billeted smoked and the ever so
recognizable winner winner chicken
dinner was first used in the ARMA 3 mod
sidenote winner winner chicken dinner is
a term that I first heard in the
terrible Las Vegas movie 21 but
apparently originated from back-alley
perhaps games they weren't exclaiming
winner winner chicken dinner as it meant
from their winnings they were able to
afford chicken for dinner that night
player unknown would also go on to make
new versions this core idea within ARMA
3 with mods like player unknowns battle
royale war player unknown street fight
and the iron front battle royale mod
which took the same gameplay mechanics
into world war ii the community took to
it with youtubers like frankie on pc
using the armor mods to tell unique and
exciting stories adding their personal
spin to the battle royale events many
more streamers and competitors also took
part in the seasons of ranked events the
shared experiences between players and
viewers would be a trend that would
follow the whole genre but also become
crucial to it
[Applause]
[Music]
unfortunately player known in the
developers that came on board to support
the armor mods weren't making much money
during its development so I can imagine
when Brendan was contacted by the then
CEO of Sony Online Entertainment John
Smedley that may have come as somewhat
of a relief this connection would be the
first steps in creating h1z1 and it's
battle royale mode king of the kill h1z1
h1z1 depending where you are started
life in a similar vein to dayz an
open-world zombie survival game with
elements of crafting and PvP it was
during its early development that John
Smedley flew Brendan green to San Diego
for talks a license player unknowns
battery al for use in h1z1 the battle
royale mode would be an official mod but
h1z1 was a different beast of the more
realistic ARMA 3 increased the player
counter 150 and even featured a crafting
system to allow combatants to create
things like armor bandages bows and
arrows classic elements like the
shrinking circle of damaging gas
parachuting into the play area and
scavenging weapons was still all present
in February of 2016 it was announced
that H when said one was being split
into two projects with two dedicated
development teams the survival part the
game becoming just survive and the
battle royale mode taking on the name
king of the kill as the game split
Brendan Green would part ways with h1n1
he would go on to comment that while he
loves what h1z1 has done with the game
mode and the opportunities it provided
him it's not wait envisioned for his own
version of the game after he handed over
complete control of the idea to hadron
said one he was able to focus on
creating the experience he always wanted
to craft h1z1 would finally really
access on PC in February of 2018 pushing
forward with its support of its
competitive eSports scene officially
launching its season one as well as a
car based mode title auto rial a few
weeks later similar mechanics you know
in cars
[Music]
[Music]
in a gaming landscape that had become
saturated with open world survival
sandboxes Ark survival evolved but its
own spin on things by adding in
dinosaurs the core game revolved around
establishing a base building a fire
gathering weapons food and taming said
dinosaurs but more importantly to the
story of Battle Royale it would
eventually feature a spin-off mode of
its own titled survival of the fittest
and released over a year later this was
marketed as a mosa
a multiplayer online survival arena an
acronym that I refused to use
nevertheless the game featured many of
the battery our trademarks the service
that it was played on would feature
special settings with leveling gathering
and taming taking place a much faster
rate as well as having stats of
dinosaurs and weapons being rebalanced
all of this was done to create a much
faster rate of play focusing on the
action and PvP elements of the game
buildings and supplies could be
accumulated much quicker than in the
core game resulting in a much faster
flow the game went down the hunger
games' method of spawning 72 players
made up of tribes would spawn around a
central island that was full of loot you
can risk being killed for supplies or
leg it into the jungle and fend for
yourself crafting base building and
creating a bunch of teams to assist you
in combat was paramount for success and
experienced players would become adept
at moving from bow combat to creating
firearms in just a few dozen minutes a
zone of death would keep players moving
into the central finale zone rather than
a zone that would slowly damage anyone
stuck in it it also featured evolution
events to make the tournament more
interesting modifiers that would
randomly occur like acid rain to drain
health and armor durability or daytime
swap to switch the day/night cycle it
was also a big push towards eSports the
original trailer featured caster
commentary and the game itself had
survivor leagues that would compete over
prize pools of over $50,000 but the last
paid tournaments were last held in 2016
and unfortunately the play account seems
to have dropped to unsustainable numbers
but in my opinion survival of the
fittest efforts should be applauded
studio wildcard made a battery our style
of game that was genuinely interesting
to watch at higher levels with a
constant ballet a building crafting
combat and like I said giant dinosaurs
next time on the car way after being an
early access for over a year
the calling became many people's go to
battle experience 16 players were given
20 minutes to explore scavenge craft and
kill with you guessed it only one
survivor standing the culling had an
airdrop and most notably a perk system
that helped it to stand out from other
betrayer games and also give players the
opportunity to create unique builds
tailored to a desired play style
combatants favouring melee combat could
call in drops with high-level Spears and
use perks to increase movement speed and
backstab damage or if you favored
utility you could take a perk that
allowed you to craft items faster the
crafting system allow players to also
play in multiple ways after you spawn
you can start punching trees and rocks
combining them into Spears or knives or
basic armor or you could head to the
nearest building and take a risk to try
finding high-level loot in lockers and
hidden structures another unique feature
was the func system func standing for
flexible Universal Nano compound
obviously func could be earned in-game
and traded in for awards or advantages
during each match activating gas tanks
hitting and killing opponents or finding
remains and barrels around the map this
could then be utilized to call in air
drops
spawn items use medical stations and
more they'll also map events that
trigger throughout a match as well as
modifiers and mutators to add variety to
around events like the shake and bake
made outside temperatures skyrocket
forcing players indoors and possibly
into confrontations or the three creep
monte which would drop three crates into
the game center finale arena but with
one having loot and two exploding with
an opening the culling leaned in to the
light-hearted gameshow style of
presentation with one of its design
pillars being a streaming friendly
battle royale unfortunately while the
culling started out strong its player
numbers started to drop off as a circle
of competitors closed in
player unknown or Brendan green has been
a common name throughout this video and
for good reason as he has helped
champion the Battle Royale genre for
years player unknowns battlegrounds is
the culmination of the experiences
learned from the armor mods as well as
h1z1 around the same time green left
Sony Online Chang Han Kim of Blue Hole
presented the opportunity to work on a
new battery our concept within a week
Brendan would be flying out to Korea to
discuss the opportunity for a new game
in the genre and weeks later taking on
the role of creative director a blue
hole and moving to South Korea to
oversee the development of his new
project
after entering early access in March of
2017 pub G drew a massive amount of
attention selling over 20 million units
before the end of the year in September
of the same year it broke the record for
highest number of concurrent players and
steam with over 1.3 million combatants
looting their way through the maps at
once the game also represents what
brendan green believes is the final
version of the concept bringing elements
that he created during his mod work all
together into this complete package Aran
Gale the first map to be in the game was
created to give players with multiple
possible options and strategies
density's open fields thick forests and
mountain peaks offer different styles of
engagements and a better suited for
different gears and play styles in an
interview with Rock Paper Shotgun Green
described the gameplay as being in three
distinct layers the air drops similar to
his ARMA 3 mod involved players figuring
out where his best to go for the highest
chance of success while also
communicating with your team looting
knowing what items are what's best to
pick up in the current situation and
quickly navigating menus to prepare for
combat and the combat game itself
engaging with other players picking your
battles moving into safe zones and
trying to secure the win streamers and
content creators have been involved in
pub G from very early versions which may
go some way in explaining how the game
grew up so quickly closed alpha and beta
periods were used to gauge initial
reactions and help to just balance
before an early access release the
explosion of interest meant that blue
hall would have to reevaluate the
production and release plan their
initial expectations were that they
would gain just enough players through
early access to smooth out the gameplay
but the surge of players meant that more
focus had to be pon stability to support
over a million combatants this led to
the initial release date being pushed by
a few months it was a huge draw for
is on sites like twitch and YouTube
before the game had even released and
naturally there was a big push to
eSports celebrating the game surpassing
as 2 million copies sold blue Hall
announced a 2017 charity Invitational
with a hundred and twenty eight players
competing on Twitch to raise money for
the game's outreach foundation after the
2017 games come Invitational surface
some issues on the logistics of such a
large event blue hole opted to work with
ESL to make running pro pub G manageable
and adapt it into a format that is
interesting to spectators in October of
2017 the China audio video and digital
publishing Association issued a
statement that discouraged battle style
games as they were too violent and
deviated from Chinese values of
socialism this however didn't dissuade
Chinese players from dropping into
Miramar or arendelle many were using
proxies of virtual private networks as
they were unable to easily acquire the
game in China to secure publishing in
other areas the Asian market like Korea
blue hole had to tone down the violence
which was done by changing the color of
blood to blue a change that some players
added to their games in western regions
too believing that the blue mist was
much easier to see and therefore served
as an extra small advantage an Xbox one
and mobile version the game would follow
the winners release one advantage that
pub she had by joining the Xbox game
preview program is that it also got the
benefit of incorporating technology and
systems from other developers under
Microsoft's banner the seer thieves team
even lended their water rendering
technology to blue hole allowing pub G
to better present the Shores around
errand girl player nose battlegrounds
has firmly cemented itself as its height
in the genre and a pillar of battle
games it even enjoyed its status as king
of the hill for a time but on September
26 2017 an unexpected contender to the
throne appeared
put the camera gun Showtime in 2011
former epic design director Cliff
Bleszinski introduced a trailer for a
game that was something in a style
previously unexplored by the studio
before and I was born as a corpse off of
a sandbox game that released into early
access in July 2017 four-night is set on
earth when 98% the world's population
disappears and shambling creatures rise
to attack the surviving members of
humanity players up to build scavenge
and craft to defend their objectives and
try to weather the storm but while the
original game launched to a middling
fanfare its battle royale mode would
propel the name fortnight into the skies
above any storm their free-to-play
battle royale mode arrived as an early
access title for Windows Mac ps4 and
Xbox one in September of 2017 with the
mobile version following much later
according to epic creative director
Donald mustard the staff in the studio
with big battery our fans with many of
them even playing pub G and once in to
experiment if fortnight could serve as a
good foundation for the game mode to try
and ensure it had a healthy growth next
to pub G the game was released as
free-to-play supported by micro
transactions in the form of ebooks which
allowed players to purchase skins and
battle past challenges the basics of the
new mode were developed in just two
months starting after the save the world
mode had shipped any complex features
the weren't already in place was saved
into the backbone of the game was in
solid and they already had an enjoyable
experience to build upon shortly after
the announcement though Blue Hole issued
a statement calling out similarities
between pub G and fortnight as well as a
lack of communication with epic this
they felt was an issue as epic is the
creator of the Unreal Engine 4 the
engine the Blue Hole license to build
battlegrounds blew holes Chang Han Kim
wrote after listening to the growing
feedback from our community and
reviewing the gameplay for ourselves we
are concerned that fortnight may be
replicating the experience for which pub
G is known we've also noticed that epic
games references pub G in the promotion
of fortnight to their community and in
communications with the press Shang Han
Kim continued this was never discussed
with us and we don't feel that it's
right blue hole also went on to threaten
further action but thankfully nothing
has come of the threat and while there
are players like me that enjoyed both
titles or many out there that gravitate
to one title in particular there would
always be a rivalry between these two
games simmering under the
surface fauna is also a game that's had
incredible successes outside of the game
itself becoming just as much of a shared
experience online as it was a personal
one streamers like ninja have shared
hundreds of their games of the
passionate audience at one point even
being joined by hip-hop artist Drake for
a few rounds and if a Titan of hip-hop
wasn't enough for tonight also added
another mad Titan in the form of The
Avengers infinity war event allowing
players to fight for the Infinity
Gauntlet and become Thanos himself the
shared experience that for now is
creating is also helping it break
records of its own Spanish youtuber el
Rubeus oMG organized an event with 99
other youtubers on March 25th that
livestream peaked a record-breaking 1.1
million concurrent viewers a record for
live streams that was previously held by
ninjas stream with Drake on Twitch and
for breaking the record for most videos
uploaded in a month on a single game
before and I may also be close to the
throning minecraft and becoming the most
viewed game on that platform not built
from wood stone or steel epic used
streamers and content creators to build
their battle experience into the Titan
the genre it quickly became but while
pub G and 49 battle it out to be crowned
king of battle royale developers aren't
being put off the idea of rising up
themselves and being counted among the
best of Battle Royale the rep lens of
early access titles that are trying to
make the most of the battery aisle craze
SOS the ultimate escape has pivoted away
from their artifacts gathering gameplay
elements to focus more on battery ow the
Darwin project is attempting to stand on
its own by using audience participation
and its director and spectator
interactions and while is unfortunate
the Bosque is now shut down they made a
really good go at breaking into the
genre with their larger-than-life retro
stylings of radical Heights not to be
outdone by smaller studios black ops 4
is having a battle royale mode of its
own and if rumors are to be believed
battlefield and even Red Dead Redemption
2 are reportedly experimenting with a
battery our formula many have responded
to these rumors with a disdain feeling
as if too many games are leaning into
the current hot trend personally though
I'm very excited I'm a firm believer
that competition can create a better
product and would be super interested in
seeing what other Studios can do with
this formula
but I want to know what you think so let
me know your thoughts in the comment
section below or if I've missed that
your favorite battle our moment feel
free to shout at me on Twitter
I'm a regular Dave but if you liked the
video make sure you hit that like button
and tell us what history offs
you'd like to see next now I have to go
because the zone is slowly closing in
but until the next time stay safe loot
well and I will see you in the next one
you